the polar bear became the heart of the
film it's the key element and it's what
tugs at your heartstrings when you see
this movie this film centers on polar
bear mothers and their cups and
protective relationship that the mothers
have with their little ones
we're way north and the Bears were just
kind of swimming you know from one
little ice pull out to another we were
able to film with a mother polar bear
and her two cubs for seven days and that
was incredible because we got to see her
throughout that entire time nurse her
cubs she was chased by other polar bears
we saw her hunt for seals and we got to
see her actually teach her two cubs the
way to act in this difficult environment
I I couldn't believe that we saw this
mother polar bear in her to seven month
old Cubs knew that we were going to harm
them which allowed us to get close to
these polar bears normally if you have a
female with Cubs they're very skittish
very afraid of people especially big
boats when I stop the engines they kick
straight over to investigate us and
trying to smell us and yeah the cops
were also paying around here they're not
afraid at all it's very rare to see two
cups at this distance it's not common at
all that one little cub was trying to
get the mall and he didn't want to get
his feet wet so he's looking from one
little place to the other and he finally
jumps on this one iceberg in the burgh
tips over he's going around a circle
though that was exciting i must say we
got footage that is absolutely
dating and stunning we were so fortunate
so lucky to come across this special
mother polar bear and her two cousins I
don't think that there's a kid out there
that hasn't fallen in love with a polar
bear and I fell in love with him myself
if we can change global climate to the
extent that the melting ice caps are
halted or slowed even it'll be better
for our kids and their kids
you